اهلين صباح الخير سهام انا في نزوه لست في
مسقط هذه الولايه الرائعه جدا ومحافظه
طبعا محمد من محافظه الداخليه في همم
سلطنه عمان تابعوا التقريبه عن مسقط يمكن
ساعه ونصف تقريبا زياده 150 كيلو طبعا هنا
ساسكت قليلا احتراما وتقديرا لي المطبخ
العماني الرائع ينضم اليك ابو رياض استاذ
سعود الجمودي وايضا احدى زوجاتهم صباح
الخير صباح النور
قبل كل شيء فكره انك تتزوج ثلاث سيدات
وتجمعهم في بيت واحد يساعدوك في المطعم
كيف جاتك الفكره والله شوف هي الفكره اكيد
انه موجوده
انت الحين بتفتح مطعم المطعم محتاج له
امور كثيره اذا ما عندك بدايل ما يمكن
يعني يعني لابد انك تكون عندك حد موجوده
في المطعم وحداني موجود في البيت ما يمكن
انك تحط زوجه واحده موجوده
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرجال يعادل بيننا ما عنده مشكله
طيب خلينا نتكلم على الاكلات اول شيء
عندنا الان الشواء العماني هذا مشوي
بالاوراق المشروع انا اكثر عنه الشيء
والعماني اييه هو طبعا مدفون
موجود في ورق الموز
وعندك شوع
هذه اعطيناك هات طبعا ما يخلى من التبذير
العمانيه والخل العماني ضروري جدا يكون
موجود في الشغل
دائما مرتبط بالشواء العماني في اي بيت
عليه حمص علي بصل
في اكيد
البهارات
يجي مع الرخال ومع العسل العسل العماني
وعندنا هنا العيش البرياني العيش البرياني
وعندنا لحم الجمل عاده كلمه عن الصالون
السمك
السلطنه عمان من اهم مصادر همم الغذاء
عندهم الثروه السمكيه الاسماك عندكم
متنوعه جدا في عمان
الشواطئ العماني صباح العماني 3,000 يعني
ما سهله
طيب خلينا اول شيء انت قلت قبل شويه نجرب
هذه اللحم بالعسل
مخبوز على الصاج
بسم الله بالعافيه عليك
اللحم نحطهم العسل
[موسيقى]
واشرف نفس الشيء والتحضير والتقدير ما في
حاجه تطلع هنا للبوفيه بدون اشتراكك
وشغل المطعم شغل البيت الحمد لله في عندي
حد في البيت
حلو يعني في تعاون بينكم الحمد لله طبعا
هم هنا ايضا عاملين لنا كيكه اهداء لقناه
العربيه
لام سلطان الزوجه الثانيه
يعني صراحه عائله جميله جدا وفي تعاون
كبير بينهم طيب ابو رياض نتكلم عن الاقبال
على المطعم كيف شايف اقبال سياحه اتكلم
الاجانب لما يجوا الاكل العماني كيف رده
فعلكم تكون شوف السياح احنا لما يروحوا
عيدوا ولا اكيد
يقرب المطبخ
المقلي
عوال مجفف مع البصل
مع
البصل مع الجلجلان مع شويه ليمون وعندك
بصل ثوم طبعا
احنا نسميها بالسعوديه المراسيه تقريبا من
المراسيه هذه ايش مكوناتها هذه اسمها
العسل
مشهوره عندنا في سلطنه عمان واكثر شيء في
فصل الشتاء هذه مكوناتها هي من الطحين
البر والدبس عسلي الدبس والفلفل الاسود
والسمن العماني والزعفران
ايضا عندنا هنا هذه الاكله قلت لي تؤكل في
الاعياد والمناسبات خاصه عيد الفطر وعيد
الاضحى هذه تقريبا تشبه عندنا في السعوديه
السليك قريبه من السليك تقريبا نحكي عن
مكونات ابو رياض هذه عرسيه
العرسيه مكونات
العيش مع طبعا الترسي المرتبطه بالعرسيه
ضروري مع السمن العماني مع الهيل
بعض منهم يسويها بده دجاج ولبعض اخر
يسويها باللحم الحين
شوي وليد
فكره عن الطابق الجميل هذا
ولذيذ جدا على فكره لذيذه جدا فعلا ما
يخلوا بيت في الاعياد ما يسوى هذا الوجبه
حد منهم يسوي حادث
العماني معروف يعني مشهور
الخليج عموما ابو رياض شكرا جزيلا سعداء
كنا معك اليوم عائله رائعه صراحه الله
يخليكم لبعض يارب ولازم تفكر موضوع الراب
انا بس نادين سهام نادين سهام شو رايكم
بالفكره المطعم وزوجات الثلاثه في زوجه
رابعه جاي بالطريقه ايضا وبرضوها هتخليها
تساعدك في المطعم اكيد اكيد
ايش رايك تمام
ههه